peut-être que comme moi vous avez
longtemps hésité à donner votre sang
pour moi c'était la peur des aiguilles
pourtant j'ai sauté le pas il y a deux
ans avec Julien Leroy derrière la caméra
on va vous montrer comment ça se passe
s'il y a de nombreuses collectes mobiles
des dons peuvent être faits à la maison
du don du généreux cancourt je suis
accueillie par un membre de l'équipe de
collecte qui vérifie mon identité et me
donne un questionnaire à remplir avec
une bouteille d'eau à bois entièrement
mon questionnaire est rempli je patiente
avant de rencontrer un médecin
l'occasion de faire le point avec
Stéphane Noël le directeur de l'efsi de
France Stéphane Noel bonjour bonjour
Alors on dit que historiquement les
stocks sont bas c'est toujours le cas en
2023 leur historiquement on espère qu'il
le soit jamais trop bas et notre travail
sans permanence d'anticiper les choses
pour faire en sorte que tous les jours
les patients de la région et les
produits sanguins dont ils ont besoin
pour être pris en charge donc oui nous
rencontrons régulièrement des périodes
de fortes tensions sur les stocks et
tout ça on l'a rencontré beaucoup
pendant la crise covid on l'a rencontré
en d'autres circonstances pendant les
ponts durant le printemps et puis
actuellement c'est la rentrée la rentrée
classiquement une période pendant
laquelle les stocks sont tendus voire
très tendus ce qu'il faut bien avoir en
tête c'est que les produits sanguins ont
une durée de vie qui est très limitée 42
jours pour les concentrés de globules
rouges 7 jours pour les plaquettes et de
fait tous les jours il faut absolument
reconstituer les stocks des produits qui
ont été consommés la veille
bonjour c'est le moment du rendez-vous
avec le médecin pour s'assurer que je
peux donner j'ai bien entre 18 et 70 ans
et je pèse au moins 50 kg mais secret
médical oblige cette séquence ne sera
pas enregistrée si l'on connaît le
fameux O négatif les groupes sanguins de
personnes originaires des continents
africains indiens au des carrés ils sont
très recherchés on les appelle les 100
rares bonjour
c'est enfin le moment de donner claire
marron infirmière va s'occuper de moi on
y va chère Madame on y va c'est le
passage le plus compliqué pour moi mais
pas de douleur particulière pas plus
qu'une simple prise de sang en moyenne
c'est entre 8 et 10 minutes d'accord
c'est pas un concours parce qu'on
prélève quand même 480 ml donc il faut
que votre organisme ce soit d'accord les
10 minutes sont écoulées on peut passer
au moment convivial 20 minutes sont à
respecter pour s'assurer que vous pouvez
repartir boisson collation et échanges
avec l'équipe et voilà le don est
terminé ça nous a pris une heure très
exactement à la fin on m'a remis un
document avec des consignes à respecter
pendant les prochaines heures et les
prochains jours prochain dont pour moi
peut-être dans un peu plus de 8 semaines
le but ne pas dépasser les quatre sur 12
mois complets